but tonight we start with the nfl and
the raiders holding practice over to
legion stadium
in less than a week from now they'll
hold their first preseason game of the
year
when seattle rolls into las vegas it's
going to be fun players having a chance
to kind of run around this afternoon
though inside the big two billion dollar
facility
they invited season ticket holders now
it's a sunday in august raider players
coaches fans media members migrated into
the stadium
and they noticed the fans yes they did
the key players ran
through the tunnel like it was game day
and the afc west was on the line
well the as we mentioned six days away
from that preseason game their first of
2021
a lot needed to happen here we're not
talking about blocking and tackling the
seahawks
just the work beginning for john gruden
and that silver and black team
but one thing that they all noticed and
got a glimpse of today were those
raider fans raider nation that rolled
into vegas and the stadium
it's a new home for us you know we came
obviously last year didn't see any fans
at our home games
uh what raider nation uh raider fans are
special
and uh to have him in legion stadium for
the first time was
was very very very good it was a blast
it was a lot of fun
for us as players i think having the
fans around again
it just creates that atmosphere that we
all crave so much
and um i it was it was quite enjoyable
and i can't wait to see this thing
sold out and packed and you know our
fans always bring the juice so
it's gonna be it's gonna be a lot of fun
most definitely like
when you can see things going well and
you can just envision
the great turnout that we plan on having
you definitely feed off of that and
that's what makes you happy
it's a very beautiful venue and i can
only imagine
what it's going to look like full but
the fans were awesome today and um
you know just going around at the end
shaking everybody's hand i was like
dude these people are crazy man and it's
awesome to see that and
i can only imagine what it's going to
look like this season and it's exciting
it's an exciting venue to be in
there